i identify as korean that's just my
culture that's my home country
that's exactly how i look now but people
are very angry at ali london was menu so
yeah bro hmm
bigotry ali london is just as korean
as caitlyn jenner is a woman just as
korean
big news coming out of britain i think
groundbreaking news
a british influencer named ali london
is uh a non-binary person they have
identified
as non-binary but not only that ollie
london
because ali london is a fan of
apparently something called k-pop
i will admit that i was not informed on
this particular trend it is korean pop
ali london is a big fan of a particular
korean
pop star named park jimin and
decided to have 150 000 worth of plastic
surgery
in order to quote unquote look more
korean and now ali london identifies
as trans korean here's holly london
explaining
their his
new identity or anyone online as british
because i
i identify as korean that's just my
culture that's my home country
that's exactly how i look now um
and i also identify as jimmy and that's
my career name but uh
not only that i just i know it's a
little bit confusing for some people
nobody's ever come out as jimin or
korean but um
this is something that you guys know if
you've followed my journey for the last
eight years i've really struggled with
identity issues
with who i am trans koreans
are koreans let me put it trans
koreans are koreans
okay and if i say it over and over it
becomes true now you're gonna have to
explain to me why ollie london is not a
korean
really and if you say things like while
ali london has never been korean
yes but trans women are not women i mean
not a single trans woman has ever been a
woman not one
and if you say well you know ollie
london doesn't even have any of the
characteristics of being a korean absent
surgery
i will say to you neither does a trans
woman and if you say to me
that ali london has never gone through
the experience of actually
being korean didn't grow up korean i'll
say neither has a trans woman
there are zero distinctions none
between being trans korean and being
a trans person of another sex none
in fact the only distinctions cut in
favor of being transracial rather than
transsexual
you can more easily shift your race
which is in fact a fluid concept
right race is a social construct
apparently if race is a social construct
you should be able to fluidly shift
between them
between the races far more easily than
sex which is a biological
concept deeply ingrained and rooted
so if you say trans women are women and
if you say that everybody's a bigot if
you refuse to acknowledge that trans
women are women because they're not
then you need to tell me right now
explain to me that if olly london had a
bunch of surgeries
to appear like a woman or more like a
woman and then said i am a woman you
would all be cheering the bravery
so brave so wonderful so
non-stereotypical
so just it's not playing on stereotypes
it's not reducing
femininity to a bunch of surgeries and
gender dysphoria
no no no it tr he would be a woman now
but if he identifies as a korean
absolutely not wrong
can't do it and so i say to you during
pride month
okay it is pride month live your truth
ollie
live your truth ali london is just as
korean
as caitlyn jenner is a woman just as
as caitlyn jenner is a woman now you may
say well olly london is just a
performance
artist it's all pro that doesn't matter
you don't get to invade ali london's
truth you don't get to tell ali london
what they
are by the way ali london has now
declared
their pronouns ali london's
pronouns it should be noted are now they
them
core en i'm not kidding you those are
those are the pronouns
and i've been told that there are many
different types of pronouns by no less a
source than the new york times
that people have been using neo pronouns
so there really is no problem here
and in fact if you don't like this you
are a bigot
so apparently ollie london then uploaded
a flag of south korea lgbt in pride
and said yes i identify as korean yes
i'm non-binary yes i look like jimin
but none of us none of this should be a
reason to outcast me from society to
dehumanize me and shame me for being who
i am
a non-binary korean person london's
manager says
that london felt strongly attached to
korea and the korean culture and feels
much more connected to this than his own
culture
but people are very angry at ali london
you bigots i don't understand why you're
mad why are you mad
what's making you so mad bro bigotry
i sense bigotry in fact as ali london
their self
now says quote how come all the woke mob
will devote all their time to
threatening and bullying me for being
non-binary but won't speak out against
human rights abuses in china how can
woke our silence on china's
concentration camps
clamp down on democracy in hong kong or
oppression in tibet
not a terrible question ollie london ali
london also writes
i'm calling out the woke mob these are
the people that always preach about
liberalism tolerance and respecting
others but are some are the same people
sending me thousands of death threats
telling me to take my own life and
bullying me because i don't agree with
who i am
hypocrisy and as holly london tweets out
being transsexual is the same thing as
being transracial
because you are born in the wrong body
live your truth ali london
live your truth ali london is just as
much a korean as ali london is a
non-binary person
and um and anybody who denies this just
during pride month of all times to deny
this
during you people
you bigots i know what you're thinking
it's time to binge some more ben shapiro
videos well you are right
you should but first like and subscribe
perfect i'll see you in the next video